Stargate is getting its own Freeview
Channel but there's a little bit more
information with that deal
that might point to something a bit
bigger welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and move your Channel
so it is exciting that Stargate is going
to be getting its own free V channels uh
look it's got Pluto on in America we
don't really get that here in the UK so
we are hoping actually that Stargate is
going to be appearing on the Freeview
channels over here as well and freebie
appears in a few different areas the
United States Europe et cetera we don't
actually know for certain whether it's
going to appear or not but I can say
this I actually flicked through the
Freeview channels
um the other night looking to see if I
could see anything and actually there
are a few channels it says to be
confirmed so I'm hoping that means those
are the Stargate channels but it's not
just Stargate that was actually
announced we're actually also getting an
outer limits TV channel on freebie now
I've already said to you a couple of
times now that it is strongly rumored
that Outer Limits will also be returning
there's also going to be an MGM couple
of channels just like classic MGM stuff
going on there this really is the first
time we've seen Amazon properly start to
use its IP that it spent all that money
on last year buying when it bought MGM
but the interesting thing is Warner
Brothers have also got a couple of
channels as part of this new deal now
Amazon and Warner Brothers have lots of
deals around the world here in the UK
HBO Max or Max
um has a deal with sky so Sky Atlantic
is basically the HBO Max channel here in
the UK in the rest of the world
HBO Max doesn't exist but it does appear
on Amazon Prime if you actually Google
Amazon HBO deals you'll see that over
the last 12 months or so they've slowly
been getting more and more of these they
call them HBO Max passes which basically
gives you access and you can pay and
basically get HBO Max on Amazon Prime
now why do I mention this
well if you regular site tracker you'll
know that we've been talking an awful
lot about Amazon's need to get a partner
to make Stargate but not just Stargate
lots and lots of other projects MGM
has already been making movies with
Warner Brothers the recent Creed movies
were done in partnership with Warner
Brothers they basically use their Studio
space and they partnered with the studio
to make those movies
we believe that Amazon is looking to get
a more permanent deal with somebody like
this because Amazon don't own Studios
Warner Brothers owns one of the largest
studios in the world the other thing is
Amazon about six months ago and now so
they're going to be spending over a
billion dollars a year to produce
straight to cinema movies now to do that
to actually start producing something
where they're going to be releasing five
or six movies a year
they're going to need a studio partner
they're going to need somewhere that
they can have a very large section of
Studio space all year round constantly
working
now a couple of Industry insiders have
been talking about this for a little
while they've been telling me that look
they have to do this deal and when they
do it'll be worth a shed load of money
why would Warner Brothers do that though
because they need a shed load of money
Warner Brothers is struggling at the
moment they have got significant debt
we've seen this with David zazlev taking
over at Warner Brothers in the last few
months that they have cut costs at every
opportunity and they are looking to get
HBO material content on lots and lots of
different platforms around the world
again making money
so why are Amazon actually doing this
deal and why are they putting Stargate
on these Freeview channels
well
from the Stargate point of view there
are a couple of possibilities here there
could be testing the waters to see if
there is actually an appetite for
Stargate now I actually disagree with
that theory because I think they've been
doing that for the last 12 months the
fact that Stargate went on Pluto the
fact that they um put it on Amazon Prime
in the United States and then took it
off again then put it back on again the
fact that they um removed it from Sky
over here in the UK and then put it on
MGM plus they've been moving Stargate
around I think purposefully to try to
judge what the interest actually is
the fact that they're now putting on
freebie really is irrelevant they've
already got that data there is obviously
also the possibility they are putting it
on Freeview which is a platform they
have been desperately pushing for quite
some time now because it actually has
really good Revenue because it has
adverts on it it is possible they're
putting it there to drum up more
excitement about Stargate it's like
basically a big advert for the project
they're about to announce
or it is actually just an example of
them taking advantage of the IP that
they own but we should take some
reassurance from that because they've
took Stargate and they've got an MGM
Channel which has got MGM stuff on it
now Stargate could have just appeared on
there but they haven't done that they've
created an outer limits Channel and
they've created a few Stargate channels
I imagine it's going to be sg1 SGU and
SGA sort of like just running in you
know cycle constantly
so that really does again emphasize that
Amazon know that Stargate is one of
their biggest franchises they know that
it's the sleeping giant of sci-fi which
is something I've been talking about for
18 months and they know they need to
take advantage of it but what about this
deal with Warner Brothers does that mean
Warner Brothers could be making Stargate
now I've been told for a little while
now that there was really a choice
between Sony or Warner Brothers
and Sony even though they have really
strong links with Amazon as well there
and they have really strong links
actually with penguin and Parker who we
think is going to be developing the new
series
Sony are a little bit difficult to deal
with and I was speaking to somebody just
last night who said look at Sony are
expensive to deal with they have really
negotiate hard they are very difficult
to deal with just look at the Marvel
arguments over the last few years over
Spider-Man and generally speaking
they do things on a project by project
basis whereas Warner Brothers might be
open to signing some sort of multi-movie
multi-year deal Sony probably wouldn't
be
so we're leaning away from Sony in that
case
but there is a risk we know Bad Robot
has pitched for Stargate we know they
actually pitched twice now Jenny stiven
who was actually involved with Stargate
command she was involved in Stargate
confirmed that this was true on a dial
the gate um last August
so
why do I mention Bad Robot because Bad
Robot has an exclusivity deal with
Warner Brothers the only way Bad Robot
could be pitching for Stargate is if
Warner Brothers have agreed it
and in that case Warner Brothers
involvement makes it possibly more
likely the Bad Robot could actually end
up being the production team that
produces Stargate we know they pitched
once and it didn't go well they pitched
a second time and we actually don't know
how that went
it has gone a little bit quiet since but
the pitches ended around there now we
know that Mark Fergus did negotiate with
MGM about doing this project about doing
the development work for it but we also
know those negotiations ended around
Christmas time and we don't know if they
restarted
now Amazon have locked down on a lot of
this a lot of my sources are saying
nobody's talking about it at the moment
I'm getting a few little bits of
information from like agent side of
things that are giving us a few little
tidbits but even them are saying to us
look
an MGM executive approached me about
this and they wanted to talk to this
person but they would not tell me what
it's about
we are putting two and two together and
we think it might be about a new big
project at MGM and we think that might
be Stargate but we don't know for sure
because no one's talking now why is that
is because the development work is
really going into full swing now I
believe that Amazon actually probably do
already have a partner or at least a
plan to get one I believe the
development work has already started and
I believe that is going to be a movie as
cinematic release of the new Star game
does the deal with Warner Brothers make
sense 100 it does
one of the things I was told was that
Amazon want to do Stargate as a
multi-platform project now that might
mean I know this is going to upset
people but it might mean cartoons it
might mean cartoon movies now that could
actually bring back things like sg1 we
could get an sg1 movie where Richard
Dean Anderson everyone basically comes
back and voices characters we could see
even characters that have unfortunately
passed away voiced by other people
thinking about the Babylon 5 project
that Warner Brothers doing right now
where they've got other actors to come
in and play the roles of some of the
actors that have passed away so we could
see a classic SG-1 episode done in that
way we've heard lots of rumors about the
potential for an SGU conclusion maybe
that would also be much easier to do in
an animation rather than actually
something that's filmed and because it
would be much cheaper I actually suspect
that could be a much easier and safer
project for MGM and Warner Brothers to
do Amazon need a strong Studio partner
if it's going to fulfill its Ambitions
for the next 10 years and getting all of
these movies to cinema the reason why it
bought MGM was to get one credibility
but also access to all this IP we are
seeing them start to take advantage of
that IP by these Freeview channels that
are being planned down by other
announcements that we're expecting soon
this is now going into full swing we can
expect Amazon to really start tapping
into all of these IP projects that
they've bought through its acquisition
of MGM we've had delay and delay while
they get ready but now it really does
seem like the starting pistol is raised
and they're about to Fire and then it
will be go go go but I'd love to know
what you think get into the comments
would Warner Brothers be a sensible
option at the end of the day it would
only be Studio space Maybe
but I think if there's going to be a big
maybe billion dollar deal with Amazon
they're going to want at least some
influence
Warner Brothers does seem to be being
better run at the moment than it was
maybe a couple of years ago
so could this be a marriage made in
heaven or does it open the door to
potentially Bad Robot getting involved
which is something we really really
don't want
get to the comments and tell me exactly
what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
you know what to do come on hit those
buttons also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos do Premiere first and you
get to see them without the adverts
which is a bonus
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]